periodistas de todo el mundo reciben
amenazas como esta cada día son las
imágenes de la campaña de la unesco para
este 2 de noviembre día internacional
para poner fin de la impunidad de los
crímenes contra periodistas
entre 2006 y 2020 más de 1200
periodistas fueron asesinados según el
organismo 9 de cada 10 casos siguen sin
resolverse judicialmente
organismos internacionales denuncian la
impunidad en los casos de trabajadores
de medios de comunicación en octubre dos
periodistas perseguidos recibieron el
premio nobel de la paz
la filipina maría reza y el ruso dmitri
murátov
el comité para la protección de los
periodistas avisó entonces sobre el
peligro que entraña hoy la profesión
la situación es terrible porque los
periodistas están amenazados como nunca
antes hay cifras récord de periodistas
encarcelados la libertad de prensa está
en retroceso en casi todas partes
ue-américa latina es la región más
peligrosa para el periodismo entre 2011
y 2020 139 periodistas han sido
asesinados según reporteros sin
fronteras
datos de la sociedad interamericana de
prensa indican que en 2021 ya han
acabado con la vida de 11 profesionales
de la comunicación
méxico es el país más violento en los
últimos días fueron asesinados dos
reporteros y como es habitual todavía no
hay ningún detenido
unesco denuncia que el 87 por ciento de
las muertes en el mundo quedan impunes
las víctimas suelen cubrir temas de
crimen organizado y suelen vivir en
pueblos pequeños
la búsqueda de la verdad es un trabajo
de riesgo en muchos lugares y como
denuncia en este día unesco la violencia
contra la profesión pone en peligro la
democracia en la libertad
[Música]